President Trump will fly to Singapore
tomorrow morning leaving the G summit g7
summit in Quebec early for his meeting
with Kim Jong moon the president said
yesterday if the meeting goes well he'd
consider inviting Kim to the US but he
also repeated that he would be willing
to walk out if the talks don't make
progress bianna golodryga is here with
the challenges the stakes and the
delicate diplomatic dance beyond good
morning delicate and good morning we are
just four days away and as with so much
of his presidency Donald Trump is
building up his highly anticipated
meeting with Kim jong-un as must-see TV
teasing us with what will no doubt be
the world's most viewed meet and greet
and the stakes well they couldn't be
higher given the 25 years of failed
negotiations I think the president has
made that bold move saying I'll meet him
I'll give him that major deliverable and
hopefully we'll move forward ambassador
Joseph - [ __ ] is guardedly optimistic
about the North Korea summit between
2003 and 2006 he was the US special
envoy for six-party talks with North
Korea I think North Korea wants a normal
relationship with the United States Kim
jong-un has made it very clear with his
New Year's address in 2018 his focus now
is on the economy given how much effort
how much money how much investment he's
made into this nuclear program it begs
the question why give it up I mean we
have to be realistic hopefully this is
what will transpire at the summit is
that Kim jong-un articulates very
clearly that he has made the strategic
decision to give up his nuclear weapons
and missile delivery systems in exchange
for security assurances economic
development assistance and a normal
relationship with the United States
president Trump's own advisors
reportedly worry about how prepared he
will be going into the meeting I began
to prepare very much it's about that
it's about willingness to get things
done but I think I've been preparing for
this summit for a long time I actually
think that they might have good
chemistry believe it or not Sumi teri
the Korea chair at the Center for
Strategic and International Studies says
president Trump could hit it off with
Kim Jong Hwan
he's very gregarious he's very different
from his father who's an introvert and
kind of antisocial and kind of a strange
guy and Terry says the optics matter
well I don't know what Kim Jong is gonna
do about the height difference because
kim Jelen doesn't want to look in any
way small both physically or just
symbolically in diplomacy any gesture
from a lingering handshake to who puts
the bill can carry political
significance there had been some
speculation as to whether or not the US
would be paying for his hotel room and
an accommodations for him in his
entourage do you find that controversial
at all I think was it James clapper who
had dinner in North Korea and they gave
him a dinner bill North Koreans are
notorious for this so of course they're
gonna give us a tab I think Singapore
might pay for it I think this is sort of
ongoing negotiation in terms of who's
paying Fred negotiators typically
choreograph every detail from the
entrance to the greeting but leaders do
go off-script and mistakes do happen in
2005 at a meeting with the Chinese
President George W Bush memorably tried
to exit from a door that was locked I
think the photo op is important for both
leaders to be able to sort of go back
and say they had a successful meeting
hopefully it will be start of a new type
of relationship a one that will lend
itself to peace on the Korean Peninsula
how important is that they walk out of
these meetings on the same page you know
I smile because we've had some
agreements in the past when we were
negotiating or threa and have we thought
we agreed on the language and all of a
sudden they're saying something
different so yes that's extremely
important because those elements is not
only atmospherics those elements of
process in trust right trust you know
it's very unusual I mean you're going in
to meet with this between our respective
countries there's zero trust zero trash
so the symbolism does matter but at the
end of the day it's about the substance
if North Korea wants a normal
relationship with the US it's more than
just giving up its nukes it will be
likely having to address issues like
human rights abuses illicit activities
and growing cyber threats
if the summit happens on June 12th it
could be a first step to normalization
so we shall see now both experts said
that they did think it was somewhat of a
step back that Melania Trump won't be
accompanying him because that could have
made the situation more approachable to
have the first lady's there but but but
that not that significant if I like that
we're still talking about no foregone
conclusions here thank you bianna